et revenons à présent sur les journées
européennes du patrimoine elles se sont
déroulées ce week-end dans le
département les événements que visiter
entre autres la préfecture de versailles
une foule de curieux a pu découvrir les
pièces de l'hôtel du département et de
la préfecture ainsi que le bureau du
préfet des yvelines serge morvan écoutez
les il était au micro de michael et demi
d'euros
je suis venu parce que j'ai de la
parentèle à versailles et on a profité
du fait que ce soit les journées du
patrimoine pour voir un petit peu toutes
les richesses
que l'on découvre dans cette ville on
connaît le château on connaît des allées
on connaît la grande avenue de paris
mais on ne voit pas trop ce qu'il ya
derrière les façades et ses façades
d'une cage des merveilles quand même moi
je pense que c'est intéressant de venir
découvrir des lieux qu'on peut voir tous
les jours mais qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
de visiter comme par exemple la
préfecture on peut découvrir les salons
des prêts faits c'est plus tard ya
comment ça se passe c'est près de 2600
personnes qui on a visité la préfecture
de versailles les visites théâtralisées
mise en scène par éric bouvron et 12 ans
nous avons parlé au domaine de madame
elisabeth et à l'hôtel du département à
versailles ont attiré aussi de nombreux
curieux et en tout c'est plus de 4000
personnes qui ont visité les sites du
département ce week-end